this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by Skillshare home to
over 20,000 classes that could teach you
a new life skill staring at the sky in
awe is one of the few quintessential
human experiences gazing into the vast
emptiness of space wondering where our
place in the universe stands for
millennia the mystery of these celestial
bodies captivated the human mind seeding
religions and mythical stories we
couldn't ignore the moon above us
influencing our tides or the Sun our
benevolent provider burning in the blue
sky at night individual stars melded
together into a boundless blanket of
glittering light until we began to
notice patterns in their chaos guiding
us as we explored our world these star
maps helped us make a monumental
discovery some stars in the sky moved
differently to others wandering through
the night sky planets like ours orbiting
our Sun Mercury Venus Mars Jupiter and
Saturn all visible to the naked eye were
discovered this way by ancient
Babylonian astronomers over 4000 years
ago later Galileo improved the telescope
allowing him to observe even fainter
points in the sky invisible to the naked
eye
he discovered Jupiter's moons Ganymede
Callisto IO and Europa and Saturn's
moons soon followed mostly discovered by
Cassini Uranus and Neptune had been
observed numerous times through
telescopes but astronomers continuously
mistook them for stationary stars or
comets
it was only when astronomers noticed the
circular orbit of Uranus that it was
accepted as a planet then as its orbit
was further examined astronomers noticed
deviations that could only be caused by
a nearby planet and thus Neptune our
solar system's final planet was
discovered it took thousands of years to
just discover the planets in our solar
system but in the last thirty years
we've discovered over three thousand
seven hundred and seventeen planets
orbiting star is so far away that we
will never be able to visit them with
current technology perhaps the most
fascinating planetary system we have
discovered is that of Trappist one an
ultra-cool dwarf star located 40
light-years away from our Sun which has
not only one temperate terrestrial
planet but seven each of the planets are
rocky in between the size of Earth and
Mars
the star is small and cold compared to
ours but the planets orbits so closely
to the Sur closer than mercury orbits
the Sun that they all have the
possibility of containing liquid water
and this is a lot of information about
planets that we can't even see directly
so how do present-day astronomers find
these relatively speaking tiny objects
floating in space the first planets
discovered orbiting the star were
discovered by a Belgian team using the
Trappist south telescope located high in
the chilean mountains the team had their
telescope trained on the dwarf star
waiting for a dimming of its light a
telltale sign of a planet in orbit
passing in front of the star and thus
blocking some of its light but how have
we discovered so much about the system
simply by a dimming of light in its star
if we calculate the distance to the star
using the parallax method we can
discover a lot more about the planets
passing in front of it you can see how
the parallax method works right now by
holding your thumb in front of you with
one eye open now close that eye and open
the other did you notice it appeared to
move relative to the background this is
called the parallax method and we can
use it to measure the distance to the
star but instead of closing our eyes and
staring at the sky we can take
measurements of the planets position
from opposite sides of our orbit around
the Sun we know the distance between
these two points and we can measure the
change in the Stars position relative to
the distant stars behind it giving us
the parallax angle thus we have all the
information we need to calculate the
distance to the star using some simple
trigonometry now that we know the
distance to the star we can calculate
its mass and size by observing its
apparent brightness and temperature
observed from Earth we have models for
how stars form with massive stars being
hotter and brighter than smaller stars
and so by measuring these values we can
get a lot of information about the star
that's how we know Trappist one is an
ultra-cool dwarf star now that we know
more about the star we can discover what
we are really interested in the planets
size mass and whether it resides in the
Goldilocks zone where humans could
survive to do that we need to know how
far away the planet is from the star we
do this using Kepler's third law which
looks like this it tells us the orbital
period for the planet that's how long it
takes to orbit its star here G is
Newton's gravitational constant
M is the stars mass lowercase M is the
planets mass and a is the orbital radius
we can ignore the planet's mass for now
as its minuscule compared to the Stars
if we do this for Earth it introduces an
error of just 0.001 percent the period
is measured by seeing the time between
transits and so we have all the
variables we need to calculate the
orbital radius now that we know how far
away the planet is figuring out its
diameter from the transit dimming is
simple the next bit of information
gathering requires a bit of a
perspective shift we are used to the
idea the planet's orbit a star
but it would be more accurate to say
that the planet and star orbit the
center of mass of the star planet system
which is not at the center of the star
this means the planet's mass is actually
impacting the orbit of the star around
this point the larger the mass of the
planet the larger the deviation we can
measure the magnitude of this deviation
by detecting the Doppler shift in the
star's light frequency as the Sara moves
towards us the light becomes slightly
more blue and when the star moves away
from us it becomes slightly more red
using the law of conservation of
momentum we can easily calculate the
mass of the planet we know the velocity
of the planet from the orbital radius
and period measurements the mass of the
star from our distance and luminosity
measurements and the velocity of the Sun
is measured from these Doppler shifts in
the life frequency leaving us with all
the information we need to calculate the
mass of the planet using these tools
astronomers have inferred quite a lot of
information about these planets the
seven planets orbit so closely to their
star that a year ranges from just 1.5
days for the innermost planets to 20
days for the outermost planet they are
so close packed that the planets will at
times appear in each other sky larger
than our moon appears in ours maybe the
coolest part of the entire thing is the
planetary system is named after the beer
the scientists used to toast their
discovery but it isn't all good news
because they orbits so close many of the
planets will be tidally locked like our
moon is to the earth meaning one side of
the planet will constantly face the Sun
which may restrict life to the
Terminator the narrow band of perpetual
Twilight on top of this orbiting this
closely to a dwarf star exposes it to
radiation from solar flares which can
strip its atmosphere away especially if
it is not protected by a strong magnetic
like earth for now we don't have a lot
of information on these planets beyond
their position period and mass but we'll
know more soon as the James Webb
telescope will be able to give us more
information about the atmosphere on
these planets by observing the light
that shines through their atmosphere
during transit by examining the spectrum
of light coming through the atmosphere
we can discover what gases are in its
atmosphere here we have the analysis of
Venus Earth and Mars all have the
fingerprints of carbon dioxide in their
atmosphere while only Earth has the
traits of an atmosphere rich in ozone
and water if we see results like this
coming from any of the Trappist warm
planets a worldwide toast with Belgian
beers may be in order
learning how astronomers discover our
universe is fascinating but it's
unlikely you will ever have the tools to
discover your own worlds but you can
explore the world you stand on and it's
nighttime sky using fairly inexpensive
equipment to produce incredible photos
like this you can learn how to do this
using this course on Skillshare
which will teach you how to find the
best times of month to plan your shoot
how to find derek areas in your location
how to identify and plan the stairs
you'll photograph and how to set up your
equipment this is probably my favorite
course I've ever taken on Skillshare to
date and I bet you will like it too
these days you can teach yourself pretty
much any skill online and Skillshare is
a fantastic place to do it with
professional and understandable classes
that follow a clear learning curve you
can dive in and start learning how to do
the work you love a premium membership
begins around $10 a month for unlimited
access to all courses but the first
1,000 people to sign up with this link
will get their first two months for free
so ask yourself right now what skill
have you been putting off learning while
project have you been dreaming of
completing but you aren't sure if you
have the skills to do it why not start
right now and sign up the skill share
using the link below to get your first
two months free you have nothing to lose
on a valuable life skill to gain as
usual thanks for watching and thank you
to all my patreon supporters if you'd
like to see more from me the links to my
Twitter Facebook discord server
subreddit and Instagram pages are below
[Music]
[Music]